causation physics doesn't have causation
at this in in the standard model in the
core models we call it and that is a big
error and i am really certain very
strongly with some courage and humility
that i think that we need to add that in
and i think brian correct me if i'm
wrong because we were kind of left the
ring now we're kind of like with we've i
don't know it's a draw or there was a
who went on point but i would say that
really
um we do need causation at the beginning
um
then that is that that shouldn't be that
shouldn't be because when i speak to
frank will check about it he just
he just i mean i have speaking to him
about it and he was very
very good he's very smart he's a bit
cheeky you know he should do this and
some people get prizes for that and i
was like it's just a price dude who
cares
tell me if causation is at the beginning
right and i couldn't
work on it you know i mean there are
people that talk about the causal you
know the structure joe amagio lee smolin
stephan alexander's the going to be on
soon on on this very podcast yeah no i
agree um i would i would you know maybe
maybe just just kind of rectify my
comment by saying i don't personally
have much you know faith in say the wolf
rami and which is the most kind of like
lifelike you know at least in terms of
complexity and rules and algorithmically
computable um essence that that will you
know make concrete astrophysical
predictions that laws will emerge from
it um and maybe it may be that you know
understanding life allows us to
understand artificial intelligence which
then allows us to uh make up new laws
i'm also kind of a ai minimalist but but
that's really a podcast for another time
because i i would just the wife and kids
will come and get me soon okay so then
this is the last one and it relates to
what you said about causation okay why
is this this is from kamar 910 why is
there something rather than nothing and
lee when you say causation so physicists
obviously study causal structures like
brian mentioned but those usually mean
you're within the light cone and it's as
simple as that not this caused this so
when you have a model of causation which
i'm unsure how one can formulate that
how does that not lead to an infinite
regress or either an uncaused cause that
at some point especially if you consider
time to be fundamental
which ties into why is there something
rather than nothing which is kamar's
question
yeah let me give you two cents summaries
so the theory paper i'm just finishing
with sarah right now actually tackles
that very question
and and it's except that there are there
at the beginning there is no causation
and but that causation gets baked in
when when information can be stored
about the past that can affect something
differently in the future and it's
really as simple as that and the only
reason physicists have missed it is
because they call screen it out
so all i'm asked all i'm slightly asking
for is to remove entropy
change it to assembly have time going
forward and suddenly you do have causal
cones and those causal cones actually
are limited by the light cone and i
think that brian and i one day will be
talking about assembly cosmology and
we'll be looking for those artifacts out
there but i think we'll we're a little
bit far away from that i need to prove
the theory do the experiments get the
data show the error convince peers
because right now it's just a kind of
cool idea a bit like lots of things in
string theory and you get that
mathematical structure in reality
and i think we'll be able to but we'll
have to be held account on that so it's
a really good question um but i'm pretty
sure i know where it is
what we're doing right i'm also going to
re-ask you lee so you can expound some
more but brian has to go so brian please
uh so again the question from kumar
again is why is there something rather
than nothing okay so what i thought lee
might say is the why questions are kind
of anathema even though they're the most
interesting questions and the most
natural questions my my toddler will ask
me why why why and of course lee as a
parent kurt doesn't know this yet
because he's not a dad yet but please
god you'll be a father soon uh kurt you
and your lovely wife but lee knows the
ultimate causal chain with an infinite
series of why questions lee how do we
answer our kids
i guess so i mean i just say just tell
them to to look for themselves or to
shut up asking the question right the
answer why why why why why why why why
because i said so okay there is a way we
use regression
right
because i said so but look you have a
point you have an origin
and you have a cause and effect now the
infinite regress isn't infinite what
happens is this is i just don't want to
this is the mechanism selection so what
this person does i'm sorry you have to
get you have to brian has to go and i'm
going to talk to you about so you can
keep talking about that but after brian
goes i i know what it's like to have a
wife that once you go on immediately no
no i mean mine too i think lee is is is
uh is correct and i do want to see this
and maybe i'll talk with sarah about
that when she comes on my show
but um but ultimately why questions are
not necessarily part of what scientists
should do why implies a meaning and i
think meaning you know it will bring up
questions of you know teleological
implications uh and i don't mean that
they're necessarily anathema but usually
when people ask why they mean how or
what um you know how did how did the
causal chain get established uh those
have great answers in in in cosmology as
well except they have great problems too
and great mysteries and lee alluded to
three hours ago now almost which was you
know how did the whole thing get kicked
off and and what was the initial
generation of you know a universe and so
forth you could ask why is there a
universe
but i think that the question of of of
why first of all could be trivial if it
didn't exist we wouldn't be here asking
why it doesn't exist
and uh and and there's your whiskey
that's wonderful i wish i could have
some scottish some scottish coffee at
this time of the day um but but in
reality
in cosmology as as kurt now you and i
talked you know i only i only have one
regret when it comes to cause that i was
on his channel when it had the square
root of the number of viewers that it
does now and it deserves the square of
the number if not more uh but uh but we
talked about briefly you know what are
the laws of physics are they so-called
geodesically complete can we extrapolate
the laws and chain of causality within
the light cone when you have a
singularity and lee mentioned
singularity a few times i happen to not
to believe that there is a quantum
theory of gravity at least i don't
believe is as well motivated i think
physicists get distracted by it i think
that they're pursuing the theory of
everything for the grandeur the glory
the the accolades that einstein never
lived up to that's the very first
paragraph of michio kako's new book you
know einstein died with his unfinished
symphony that he couldn't come up with a
theory of everything no despite that
being the name of this channel i think
the gut is almost you know being
overlooked the grand unified theory we
don't understand how the lower energy
forces or the higher energy force are
unified let alone how all four are
unified and who
if not you know uh one of us has the
temerity to say that there has to be a
law of quantum gravity what if there's
not so i'll channel my inner uh you know
lee and and say you know i don't believe
that there is quantum gravity because i
want to inspire my colleagues to think
harder about it and we've been going
about this for decades now with little
signs of progress um not to say to stop
even string theory which i have my
problems with um uh but the alternative
as they say you know uh the the string
theory is the worst theory except for
all the others uh that could be true
according to whitten um but but i think
ultimately the why questions are the
most interesting but we should be
careful not to ask for motivation i
think that evokes teleology but um but
also we should be very precise we should
answer all the how questions as galileo
said
measure what is measurable and make
measurable what is not yet so
and as experimentalists lee and i try to
do that i know i was cutting you off but
i know brian has to go did you want to
expand on what you were saying before
yeah just very quickly so this whole
idea for infinite regress doesn't have
to happen if you haven't if you have an
origin and you have some events to
happen like the the events are random
but as soon as they start to
um
although they're random as they go on in
time they become contingent
because what happens in the future has
some relationship to that in the past
and as long as you don't call screen it
out now
when you start to then create an object
that can then that object can then
actually
interact on the infinite regress don't
go back in the loop but not back to the
beginning and give
some knowledge from the future if you
like to the past
um then that infinite regress is not an
infinite regress it's just selection so
what that means is you have a series of
processes where you make an object so
let's just say you've got some
um some
uh chemistry occurring you've got let's
say you have two different streams of
chemistry
and they're random right but then in
each stream so you've got stream a
random stream b random and they're
becoming less random there's some
structure and then stream a
is able to interact with stream b
and to change the reaction
um so it can act back on itself with
more efficiency so that's something that
b can act back on itself yeah and then
you basically then then you get all
sorts of crazy things going because then
a and b become intertwined and mutually
dependent and then that goes up and then
this process of selection
starts to transition and i think that's
the secret but i haven't got there yet
we have seen evidence of this in the
laboratory
and i think this is the answer to the
origin of life but we need to literally
run the experiment put a heavy emphasis
on selection and i'm wondering does
section selection in your model of life
come prior to reproducing and variations
sounds like variation was there though
in the b a and the b yes so variation
was first that produced selection which
then produced actually
yeah when you have heterogeneity
and then you can get selection
uh and
this kind of variation and and things
interacting and evolution can actually
still occur on very long time scales and
these in these on these on these
infinite timelines if you like and what
happens is that biology weaponizes
evolution through through autonomous um
reproduction because it like grabs all
those causal chains and can combine them
together in one object and the way it
weaponizes is it basically
replicates the genome stores information
very efficiently from the environment
and then adapts and it can
basically produce lots of attempts
at copying itself with slightly
different causal structures and so why i
see biology is biology is like a
it creates evolution which is an
amplifier for selection
and all the universe is trying to do is
become fitter
i see i i'm having a difficult time
understanding it and i think it's
because i don't know what definition of
cause you're using to say that there was
a first cause that came from something
that was uncaused so i think that's
where my what i'm just saying you've
just got basically is let's think about
symmetry breaking so you've got a highly
symmetrical system and then things
interact
and time because the thing is this is
where physicists get really stuck in
that if you've got a time symmetric
system where does the symmetry breaking
come from you have to add something in
an imperfection
a a heterosome heterogeneity in
homogeneity
if you have time you break that symmetry
necessarily
so there's something really interesting
that we don't understand about time but
um but that's probably for another
podcast sure man
you